in 2016 a spooky white figure with wide
unblinking eyes was spotted wandering a
Green Bay Wisconsin parking lot at 2 in
the morning residents posted about their
sightings on Facebook and made calls to
the police but the strange figure
continued appearing that night in a
local park and under an overpass then it
suddenly disappeared just as
mysteriously a week later a similar be
appeared in South Carolina beckoning to
Residents from the woods over the next 2
months dozens of these mysterious
figures would pop up all across the US
and Canada along with sightings in 16
other countries around the world some
would attempt to approach children to
frighten them most appeared silently
watching but all of them were dressed as
clowns clowns are known for their
humorous Antics balloon animals and
juggling to amuse audiences whether
they're teaching us how to tell time on
Saturday morning TV or selling us french
fries so when did these silly funny
Staples of our childhoods become
monsters I'm Dr Emily zarka and this is
monstrum the history of clowns spans
centuries we associate them with bright
colored clothing oddly shaped hats
oversized shoes and painted faces our
current image of clown started taking
shape around the mid 19 century when an
English comedian and actor named Joseph
Grimaldi began performing in a polka
doted costume pointy triangular wig
ruffled collar and red and white face
paint but since the 1980s clowns have
taken a decidedly Dark Turn depictions
of clowns have taken these visual traits
from kooky to creepy by playing up
features like pale skin big eyes and a
wide unnerving
smile these creepy clowns appear like
the silly characters of our childhoods
just slightly off so why the shift even
before killer clowns were all over our
screens clown characters have occupied
an unusual place in the social order
some of the most ancient versions were
fairly problematic in places like
ancient Egypt and Rome stigmatized Iz
marginalized people many enslaved were
treated as entertainment at parties and
events for the wealthy ancient Rome also
had MIM type characters and ones who
performed unusual body stunts beginning
at least as early as the 13th century
Chinese Opera featured clown characters
called Chia who were often the only ones
on stage allowed to improvise lines and
Renaissance Era Court Jesters in Europe
were kept in Noble circles as
entertainment and were permitted to saiz
royalty and speak truths without fearing
punishment clowns throughout the world
began as trickster characters who had a
pass to flout social conventions and
behave in transgressive ways by the mid
1800s clowns began to filter from their
highclass entertainment Origins into
popular culture Joseph galdi became a
celebrity in the English theater scene
meanwhile in the US the Ringling
Brothers and barnab and Bailey set up
circus shows featuring clowns performing
slapstick comedy routines as clowns Rose
in popularity they retained their
roguish spirit it wasn't until literary
works like Charles Dickens pck papers
edar Alano's hop frog and roero Leon
cavalo's Opera piai that the clown
Persona took on a much darker tone these
depictions were some of the first to
look at The Man Behind the Mask
depicting clowns that underneath their
trickster silliness have Sinister or
even murderous
[Music]
intentions but by the mid 20th century
American clowns got a kid friendly
makeover featuring more friendly figures
like howdy dudy clarabel the Clown Bozo
the Clown and Ronald McDonald this
reflected the broad optimism and
prosperity of the post-war era but this
wholesome imagining of the clown didn't
last long in 1979 serial killer John
Wayne gasy who worked as a party clown
as a day job was arrested at the same
time the satanic Panic of the 1980s was
picking up speed this moral frenzy based
on conspiracy theories that evil
cultists were harming children made many
people anxious about who they could
trust against this cultural backdrop
creepy clowns started to become a pop
culture staple often using their
kid-friendly cultural status to lure
children to their deaths their
exaggerated facial features push clowns
Into The Uncanny Valley a theorized
point where an object her character
appears almost like a real person
without looking fully human it's that
tiny bit of disson which fills actual
human viewers with unees film depictions
use this creepy dissonance to create
frightening characters Poltergeist a
movie in which a possessed clown toy
attacks the young boy in his bedroom was
a box office hit and Batman starred
horror movie stapled Jack Nicholson
playing the joker as a villainous clown
even children's media turned clowns
exclusively scary who else has
nightmares about the evil firefighter
clown from Brave Little Toaster cuz I
hate it perhaps most famously Stephen
King's 1986 novel it features Pennywise
an evil clown that stalks the suburbs
looking for children to frighten and
kill the book became so successful that
it was adapted as a TV series by the end
of the decade solidifying the clown as
not just a man in face paint but a
monster that could transform into
whatever you fear most the 1988 cult
sci-fi horror comedy killer clowns from
outer space turned this newly minted
archetype on its head with a more
playful take on the Killer Clown
featuring murderous aliens disguised as
clowns who trap their unsuspecting
victims in cotton candy cocoons the
film's decision to steer the Killer
Clown archetype back towards its
Whimsical Origins shows how prevalent
the creepy clown phenomenon had become
the last decade has brought in another
wave of creepy clowns in pop culture
horrifying harle kins cropped up in
American Horror Stories Supernatural and
Zombie Land time to nut up or shut
up it the Joker and Poltergeist all got
darker grittier reboots but then the
clowns we love to fear on screen got a
lot less fictional in the fall of 2016
that mysterious clown appeared in
Wisconsin it didn't hurt anyone it just
broke some social norms as clowns have
always done by creeping around at odd
hours and remaining silent when spoken
to this clown didn't act quite human the
prankster eventually revealed that he
was trying to drum up publicity for an
independent horror film and it worked
photos and stories about the clown
sightings went viral on Facebook
inspiring a wave of CopyCat clowns in
more than 20 States over the next 2
months if you remember the late summer
of 2016 you know that it was a volatile
and politically divisive time it's
possible that these tricksters wanted to
let off some of the tension that was
building in their communities or to
direct anxieties at a common fictional
enemy but they successfully tapped into
the public sphere of these uncanny
valley creatures enough that some school
districts and municipalities warned
against or even banned wearing clown
costumes at Halloween for being symbols
of Terror police in Utah even received
calls about whether citizens were
allowed to shoot clowns on site and when
rumors started circulating about a clown
on Penn State's campus that October more
than 500 students took to the streets in
a so-called clown Riot to hunt the
jester down and yet just like in the'80s
clowns were more of a psychological
threat than a physical one with their
exaggerated Smiles it's difficult to
read what clowns are really thinking or
feeling underneath all that face pain
and their reputation for mischievous
Behavior makes it hard for us to predict
what they might do next and all of that
uncertainty makes us uneasy it's no
wonder that killer clowns tend to emerge
in pop culture at times of heightened
political tension or distrust in the
social contract when we're all wondering
what whether we can trust the people
around us clowns may be a symbol of
human Duality one that asks us to
consider if we all wear a little bit of
a costume when we present ourselves to
the
world roero Leo's opero Pavia piai piai
there's no V
piai did I say it right though you're
like
uh